hey Maria Pedraza we have loved watching
you play marina on delete you are such
an amazing character and a marvelous
actress too
but since you're pretty new to our
Netflix screens we don't know much about
you or your co-stars we don't know how
old you are or what else you have acted
in and we want to know everything we can
about you and the rest of the cast a
lead might be a TV series all about
Spanish teenagers but most of the stars
are a lot older than they appear to be
keep watching to find out who your
favorite elite stars are currently
dating and how old they are in real life
hello Pablo is played by actor Alvaro
Rico who is 23 years old
Alvaro started acting only recently he
has become super famous after starring
and elite he is currently filming a
miniseries called El Cid that will be
out in 2020 Alvaro is currently dating
his co-star Esther Esposito who plays
Carla so the chemistry they had
on-screen was 100% authentic Christian
Christian Varela Esposito is one of the
three transfer students in elite he is
played by Miguel Harun who is 23 years
old
Miguel has been acting since 2015 when
he was in the movie nothing in return he
won an award for best new actor for his
role in the film he was in several
spanish movies before moving to
television he is currently starring in
two shows elite and money heist wow he
must be busy Miguel doesn't appear to be
dating anyone at the moment Nadia Nadia
sheena is one of the three kids who gets
a scholarship to the elite school she
plays the daughter of palestinian
immigrants the actress who plays nadia
is nina el Himani
she may play a teenager but she is
actually 25 years old
nina has been acting for several years
on Spanish television she was on 200
episodes of severe ypres beggar which
translates to serve and protect
if Mina is currently dating anyone she
is keeping it pretty quiet
Omar on elite Omar is Nadia's
troublesome brother who falls in love
with an der Omar is played by Omar au so
yeah Pia is the same first name as his
character in real life
Omar is 21 years old you wouldn't know
it from his acting abilities but
is really new to the business he just
started acting in 2018 but elite is his
first major role he's definitely getting
recognized now for the time being
Omar appears to be single Samuel out of
the three transfer students
Samuel is one of the most popular
characters he falls in love with marina
he is one of the younger actors at age
20 even though he is one of the youngest
stars he has one of the most extensive
careers he has acted in quite a few TV
series since 2016 and he is currently
working on a movie called Lynetta
5000 we can't find any confirmation that
Samuel is dating anyone
Guzman Guzman Nuno Sunna plays marinas
adopted brother he is played by Miguel
Bernardo who is 22 years old
he was on the TV show hounds and he has
also acted in the movie it's for your
own good
Guzman is also going to be in a new TV
show called courante Miguel is dating
Athena asana she is a 20 year old
spanish singer they have been together
since 2018 and they make such a cute
couple
Marina marina is one of the most popular
characters on elite she is played by
Maria Pedraza a 23 year old actress and
dancer Maria is a trained ballerina in
real life she started acting in 2017
when she was cast in the movie loving
she also appeared in a few episodes of
CBS 2 Maria is dating her on-screen
boyfriend nano we love when on-screen
couples start dating in the real world
nano nano is short for Fernando Garcia
Dominguez he is Samuels older brother
who just got out of prison Nano is
played by Jamie learnin things he is one
of the oldest actors on elite at age 27
jamie has been acting since 2016 when he
appeared in several episodes of el
secreto de Puente Viejo he is also in
money heists with his elite co-star
Miguel Haren Jamie is dating Maria
Pedraza they makes such a great couple
both on screen and off and ER and ER
Munoz is the son of the principal and
love interest of Omar he is played by 21
year old Aaron Piper Aaron is Spanish
but was born in Germany ander is only 22
but he is one of the most experienced
actors on elite he had his first role as
an extra way back in 2004 he started
seriously acting in 2011 elite isn't the
only show he starred in in 2019 he also
acted in dyrdek Joe a sonar and ER is
currently single we wonder if he'll ever
date one of his elite co-stars Carla
Carla is a fan favorite on elite she is
played by Esther Esposito Esther is the
youngest of her elite co-stars she's
just 19 years old
Esther started acting in 2016 with two
uncredited roles but she really got her
start in 2017 on the show
estoy vivo she became really famous
after she starred in the movie when
angels sleep
Esther is dating her on-screen ex she
and Alvaro Rico are just so in love they
are so cute together
who is your favorite character on elite
and why let us know in the comments
below subscribe to our channel to be the
first to see our latest videos and click
the thumbs up button while you're at it
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]